the natural living world in his new book
climate crash he spoke about it recently
here in Washington for about 50 minutes
great well I'd like to welcome all of
you to the Marion Koshland Science
Museum my name is Erika shugart and I'm
deputy director of the museum and we're
really pleased to bring you the latest
in our continuing series of pizza and
prose with Joseph Henry press so really
glad you could make it out on this
steamy day and join us for this event I
hope that we'll see all of you at some
of our other programs like to put a
little plug for some of the upcoming
events we have next week we're going to
have science writer Steve Olsen here and
he's going to be talking about relatives
you didn't know you had and how closely
related you are to everyone else and the
planet in a program called stories of
descent that's going to be on Thursday
evening at on July 21st at 6 p.m. and
this fall we're going to have a number
of other programs lots of you here
probably because you're really
interested in climate we're going to
have a weather and climate related
program called there's a storm brewing
hurricane forecasting which will be on
September 14th where we'll see how well
they did on the hurricane forecast so
far this year not been a very exciting
year so far in hurricane forecasting Joe
palco will be here on October 20th to
discuss his approach to communicating
about science through radio as part of
our communicating science series and on
October 27th Judith lean from the Naval
Research Laboratory will be here to
discuss the impact of the sun-earth
system on global climate change so that
might be another event that you'd be
interested in and you can find more
about all these events on the handouts
you might have picked up on your way in
but also on our website which is up here
on w w Koshland science org and today's
topic is particularly relevant to the
Koshland science museum because of our
exhibit on global warming for those of
you who have not had a chance to take a
look at the exhibit or for the listeners
at home I hope that you'll find a time
to come down and go through the exhibit
and take a look I think you'll find that
it's a really interactive fun exhibit
and it's all based on the work of the
National Academies so it's a think
you'll really find it to be quite
intriguing but I know that you're not
here to see me so with no further ado
I'll introduce Jeffery Robbins who will
be introducing our speaker Jeffery is a
senior editor with Joseph Henry Press
you're not all here to see me either but
I like this big however it is my great
pleasure to introduce John Dee Cox
author of climate crash thought it was
up there which has been hailed as a
succeed analysis of cutting edge
climatological research into a
fundamental issue for all of humanity by
archaeologist Brian Fagan author of the
long summer provocative and well-written
by book list and an absorbing and
sobering new book by the Seattle Times
when Mother Jones called it a thorough
and compelling account of the
controversial study of the fickleness of
the world's climate
Cox's book has striking implications
John is a veteran journalist with a long
and distinguished career spent reporting
from the frontlines of scientific
discovery with a specialty on climate
science his impeccable credentials
include a night science journalism
fellow from the Massachusetts Institute
of Technology senior writer for the
Sacramento Bee senior speech writer
California Legislature I didn't know
that editor for Reuters limited in
London UPI in the western US and he has
been an invited participant in the
research workshop the potential use and
misuse of El Nino information in North
America under the auspices of the
National Center for Atmospheric Research
he is the author of weather for dummies
and the storm watches the turbulent
history of weather prediction from
Franklin's kite to El Nino please join
me in extending a warm welcome to John
Cox
well thank you we are yeah I think we're
okay as a Californian it's always a
pleasure in an educational experience to
visit our nation's capital Washington
offers the unique window on our history
as everyone knows here things that are
taken for granted in many parts of the
world are in Washington alive and well
not everyone appreciates the fact but
this is one of the last places on earth
for a really good knock-down drag-out
argument about the existence of climate
change can be heard but I'm not one of
those who despairs over the anachronisms
of our political process I happen to
think it's running like a perfectly
well-oiled machine but let me be quick
to say that the book is really not about
that it's not in the main about global
warming it's not about whether the
climate system is broken or who broke it
or how it can be fixed
those questions are interesting and I
don't mean to imply that they aren't
important subjects for discussion but
I'd like today to make a case for
another set of ideas that I think ought
to be on the table any time this climate
change comes up but climate crash is
about and what this talk is about is the
subject that's different than what we
think of when we use the term global
warming especially when we use it in a
political context our focus in the book
is not so much on human pollution of the
atmosphere as it is on the nature of the
climate system itself and these
differences are critical the ideas that
form the concept we call abrupt climate
change are important to know whether or
not there is global warming taking place
but let's tackle this question right
away because the answer really does have
something immediate to say to us
what does abrupt climate change have to
do with global warming
in a nutshell here is global arming the
gases of industrial pollution are
building up in the atmosphere and most
climate scientists believe that this
heightened concentration is increasing
the natural greenhouse effect more
outgoing heat is being trapped and so
mean global temperatures are on the rise
thanks to our illuminating national
debate on this subject during the last
ten years everybody knows by now that
this is a big problem or it is a little
problem or it is no problem at all along
with this concept of global warming
comes a set of assumptions about how the
world works and what our future will be
like let's see if I can make this work
chief among these is a fairly
comfortable notion about the time scale
involved things are going to go along at
a certain pace the thinking goes and
this rate of change is going to be
manageable and why shouldn't it be the
word warming implies the average
temperatures around the world will rise
gradually this is what earth scientists
have led us to believe about the way
things change global mean temperatures
are going to rise a few degrees Celsius
over the next century global mean
temperatures there's a problem with this
idea or this concept climate scientists
no doubt have very good reasons to use
such a yardstick but for the rest of us
it does no good at all
for one thing nobody lives there nobody
lives in the global mean it's regional
climate that matters we're going to have
to find another way to think about this
if the Normand same if the northern
hemisphere freezes over and the summit
southern hemisphere fries to a crisp
global mean temperatures can be
unchanged and besides a couple of
degrees Celsius sounds like nothing more
than serious than a inconvenience I
don't know about you but it surprised me
to learn that the difference between
global mean temperature between the
depths of the last ice age and the
current climate is about 5 degrees
Celsius
the future climate is composed of two
elements human-induced change on the one
hand and natural climate variation on
the other there are those who argued
that the natural part of the equation is
relatively large and others who argue
that the natural part of the equation is
relatively small both sides seem to
agree that the climate systems natural
behavior does not pose any particular
threat it is as they say only natural
another key assumption in the global
warming debate is that we if we reduce
our industrial pollution it will have
the desired effect the atmosphere will
respond accordingly
its composition will change and
temperatures will decline like turning
down the dial of a thermostat and return
for a little of this you get a little of
that
of course this seems entirely fair and
logical why shouldn't it be that way and
if it doesn't happen if there is a time
lag between the give and the get well
thank goodness for the gradual pace of
change people in the future will have
time enough to adapt to a somewhat
warmer world in other ways all these
ideas are perfectly reasonable to me as
they are to a lot of people who's
interested in the subject we've been
taught that the climate is part of the
Earth's system that grinds along in a
geological pace and we've grown up
thinking that if we have it in our power
to break something we have it in our
power to fix it
we've also grown up thinking that while
there are a few serious natural hazards
in the world like volcanoes and
earthquakes and hurricanes climate
change is not one of them the question
is whether these assumptions about the
pace of future events and our control
over them are realistic and if they are
not realistic are they too negative or
are they too positive the message of
climate crash and the science of abrupt
change is that almost certainly we are
being too optimistic
in fact if we were to try to make some
take some starch out of this subject god
forbid we might call this common
assumptions the mother Teresa concept of
the climate system are we not children
of Earth after all are we not in our
mother's arms Mother Earth will take
care of us the thinking goes all we have
to do is learn to behave ourselves all
we have to do is clean up our act now
there's another line of thought a
different set of assumptions that raises
a different question the question is
this what kind of a climate system would
behave in such a way that is not
congenial with our future well-being
well I'm here to tell you the answer is
an abruptly changing climate system what
climate scientists have recently found
out about the natural behavior of
climate puts this whole subject in a
very different context that is what
abrupt climate change is all about the
natural behavior of the climate and
here's what it has to do with global
warming for the first time the record of
the past is clear and the pattern is
indisputable when the climate system
changes very much to our surprise
sometimes the changes it's changes are
not small and not gradual but rather
they are large and rapid by rapid I mean
not only during a single human lifetime
but possibly even the span of a single
congressional term this is a climate
system that is very different from the
one you and I have grown up expecting on
this timescale the idea of adaptation
come takes on the look of an emergency
as the old saying goes Houston we've got
a problem people who are most familiar
with the history of climate are warning
us that the prospect of change poses
greater dangers than just about anyone
has supposed rather than being stable
and robust the system is chippie it is
precariously balanced
and when it changes it tends to Teeter
and wobble and then to flop in a very
DIF into a very different state of
operation and to stay in this new mode
for quite some time in a word it is
chaotic it is chock-a-block with
variables and thresholds and feedbacks
of one kind and another in the
vernacular of dynamical physics it is
nonlinear this means that occasionally
the slightest alteration in one variable
or another can lead to enormous change
quite unexpectedly some of these
features we know about and some of them
we don't a lot of work is being done on
mechanisms of abrupt change the causes
in effects and a lot of major questions
are unresolved but the message for those
of us who are not climate scientists is
already very clear anything that forces
such a system to change such as changing
the composition of the atmosphere
increases the likelihood that it will
cause a threshold of abrupt and
unwelcome change it is worth remembering
now that all of the many abrupt changes
that occurred in the past were not
provoked by human activity but let but
let's not let ourselves get too
comfortable with this thought for one
thing it is worth remembering that all
of those triggering mechanisms are still
out there for another whatever events in
processes can force such a system over a
threshold of rapid change altering the
concentration of greenhouse gases almost
certainly qualifies as one of them the
message of climate crash of abrupt
climate change is not good news in the
vernacular of the new age this is not a
user-friendly climate we are being too
optimistic about the potential
consequences of changes and our ability
to control them as you may have gathered
by now this is not to the mother Teresa
concept of climate change it is just the
opposite it is the Dirty Harry concept
of
it is menacing and unpredictable you
don't want to mess with it enough about
global warming now we have other
questions to contemplate where did this
concept of abrupt climate change come
from and if this is really the way that
climate system behaves naturally how
come it has taken so long for us for it
to come to our attention
I hope these questions are especially
interesting because these are the
questions that climate crash answers as
we have already observed only recently
have we discovered the true nature of
the system that produces what we think
of as the normal patterns of seasonal
weather the storm tracks the
temperatures the precipitation all the
things that living things rely on the
young science known as paleoclimatology
has found ways to tease important
details out of various natural archives
that extends our knowledge back beyond
the 100 years or so of records kept by
weather instruments with this new
information climate scientists are
radically changing their thinking about
the general pattern of climate history
and the pace of changes they see just a
century ago a very different set of
ideas held sway consider the words of
the Scottish geologist John Walter
Gregory in 1906 the first striking fact
in the geological history of climate is
that the present climate of the world as
Maine has been maintained since the date
of the earliest unaltered sedimentary
deposit you can see the climate profiler
at the bottom it's a fairly steady state
even even as Gregory was defining this
first striking fact however the ground
was moving under him already under wave
is a long and disputatious investigation
into the geological remnants of ice ages
this investigation is not really the
subject of climate crash abrupt climate
change is concerned more directly with
changes that occur on a shorter time
scale than the big ice age rhythms but
it's helpful to get the timeframe here
because the question of ice ages
occupied a great deal of thinking of
geologists and climate scientists
through much of the 20th century in a
sense scientists were looking over the
tops of the ridges and valleys of abrupt
climate change in search of the big
divides that marked the comings and
goings of ice ages for our purposes it
suffice us to say that the old 19th
century vision of eternal climate
stability was not long for this world
German scientists studying debris left
behind by long gone glaciers I hope this
is not too technical for you I worked on
that developed a climate profile that
that featured four Ice Age is a
relatively brief duration that
interrupted a dominant pattern of warm
stability for many years geologists
accepted this view in the 1950s however
new analyses of ocean sediments by the
Italian geologist Emilio necessary
turned this concept upside down this is
actually not a climate episode as I was
manually inputting this data my cat
bumped me
there are many more I say he found that
there were many more ice ages and in
fact the glacial periods lasted much
longer than the warm interglacial
episodes studying ocean sediments Azaria
was employing the same post-war
technology of atomic isotope analysis
that led to the discovery of abrupt
climate change in a different medium in
polar ice here's how abrupt climate
change the natural behavior of climate
was discovered the study of ancient
climate relies heavily on the idea of
proxy data one kind of evidence stands
in for another paleoclimatologists
cannot measure ancient climate
conditions directly the way weather
instruments record changes in modern
conditions but they can measure other
things to give them reliable clues about
long gone climate first to employ this
approach were scandinavian plant
scientists in the 1930s they were able
to trace advances and retreats of alpine
glaciers by identifying pollen grains of
cold loving plants left behind in the
soil under mountain meadows in denmark
and elsewhere so it happens to one
particularly well studied abrupt change
when the northern hemisphere at least
plunged back toward Ice Age cold about
13,000 years ago is named after an
Alpine flower driest petal oh and the
30s scientists really had no idea how
quickly the Younger Dryas as it is
called might have come and gone and most
tell that it was basically a relatively
regional event they held to the
conventional thinking at the time that
climate changed over thousands of years
researchers eventually discovered the
Younger Dryas as the last of a long
series of great climate crashes that
spread over vast areas of the globe
during the last ice age and here's the
smoking gun proof of
nowadays geologists often refer to the
Younger Dryas as a cold snap but nobody
who lived through through it would call
it that it was a miserably cold and
windy and dry time that lasted for
something like 1,300 years in the
mid-1950s nations on both sides of the
Iron Curtain put aside their Cold War
antagonisms long enough to conduct a
series of global research projects in
the earth science is known as the
International Geophysical Year preparing
the USA's contribution to this
enterprise a team of scientists from the
Army Corps of Engineers traveled to
Greenland to see if it was possible to
extract cores of polar ice from the ice
sheet and to see if anything interesting
could be learned from them this work in
Greenland was intended as a
proof-of-concept experiment in
preparation for the u.s. international
geophysical year project on the ice
sheet in Antarctica as things turned out
however it was the Greenland project
itself that became a real bonanza in the
polar ice of Greenland more than
anywhere else on earth
the climate has laid down a highly
detailed profile of its history that
scientists have learned to read like a
book more than 100 thousand individual
years of snowfall are stacked
sequentially on top of one another on an
ice cap that is about two miles deep in
Antarctica the ice has been found to be
much older by the way but in most places
the annual accumulation rate is not as
high and so the detail is not as good
three pioneering scientists joined
forces in the 60s to analyze the
Greenland ice core every way every way
they could think of they were the
American Chester Lange way the Swiss
scientist Hans fish Kerr and
Willy Dan's guard of Denmark they
conducted numerous physical and chemical
tests
and for the first time subjected
polarized to nuclear laboratory analysis
in a device known as an accelerator mass
spectrometer this process allowed them
to measure the relative proportions of
different isotopes stable isotopes of
oxygen in the ice
most oxygen in the water molecule is
composed of oxygen 16 but there is a
rare heavy form known as oxygen 18
object point I don't want to get into
the science too deeply but let me just
point out that the truly remarkable fact
that knowing the precise ratio of these
two forms of oxygen in a given sample
allows scientists to determine the
temperature of the air when the
particularly of ice fell as snow
thousands of years ago out of this
process in the 60s and 70s came the most
detailed picture of climate history that
scientists have ever seen more than 100
thousand years of climate was recorded
in a continuous high-resolution profile
temperatures during the whole of the
last ice age were graphically depicted
in some detail as well as temperatures
during the ten thousand or so years
since the end of the last ice age the
most surprising thing about what has
come to be known as the camp century ice
core in Greenland was the jaggedness of
it it wasn't anything like the
relatively flat smooth curve of
slumbering ice age temperatures and
gradual transitions between cold and
warm conditions the camp century course
shows all kinds of sudden jumps and
plunges in fact the early Greenland ice
cores were so different from what
climate scientists expected that they
had a hard time believing what they were
seeing these short jerky transaction
trends transitions fit nobody's idea of
what the behavior of climate was
supposed to be to researchers in the 60s
and 70s looking for patterns especially
long-term ice age rhythms it looked like
a bunch of troublesome noise
it really wasn't until the mid 80s that
abrupt climate change emerged as a
serious idea in the literature of
climate science on jiske I was lecturing
at the University of Bern showing a
climate profile from a Greenland ice
core an American researcher named Wally
Broecker happened to be in the audience
ruminating about the jerky pattern
Hershiser said it looked to him like a
quasi stable system slipping in and out
of two different modes of operation
he wondered out loud what could cause
such sudden changes at that moment the
first plausible explanation of abrupt
climate change occurred to Wally
Broecker changes in ocean circulation
could do it broker popularized a
simplified graphic depiction that links
all the world's oceans by way of a great
conveyor driving this conveyor are
differences in water density a property
that depends on a combination of salt
content and temperature changes in
density can cause this global transport
system to shut down or to speed up or to
change its pattern this conveyor
transports enormous quantities of heat
toward the poles as well as cold away
from them change this transport system
and you change climate simple as that
there are various ways to do that there
are other mechanisms of abrupt change
that have also been offered as
alternatives but the point is that by
the late 1980s abrupt climate change had
a coherent theory and a well-known
theorist also by the late 1980s global
warming was rearing its head as a
serious possibility people were
beginning to ask climate scientists
questions they couldn't answer what is
the pattern of natural climate variation
that we might expect is global warming a
big problem or a little problem or no
problem at all by the early 1990s clear
that it was time to go back to Greenland
and settle the question of whether the
abrupt changes that show up in the
I'm at profile in the ice cores are real
something like fifty million dollars was
spent on two large international ice
coring operations about twenty miles
from each other and the perfect location
atop the ice cap and their findings in
the mid-1990s did in fact settle the
matter this is what the climate record
No
well it's in the book yeah they'll have
to buy the description it's a very it's
a very jagged and and disrupted pattern
if it goes from the last hundred
thousand years is has 24 episodes of
very very sharp plunges and and climes
of temperature nearing the level of
policy noir and and then plunging all
the way back down to Ice Age call it
just it just it looked at the crazy it's
a crazy pattern nothing like what we
think of when we think of you know ice
ages of slumbering slumbering cold
this is the temperature of you know the
natural climate the footprint of the of
the climate system you expected you know
there's nothing about what I would like
to show you that that suggests
gradualness it's all very abrupt in in
ragged it's a global signal not just
Greenland using the same kind of stable
isotope analyses as well as other
ingenious methods researchers have found
this pattern these episodes in other
archives such as ocean sediments around
the world the last ten years the last
ten thousand years in this pattern is
this is this sort of sawtooth thing at
the very top very much more stable
looking than the rest of the Ice Age
period the temperature sort of level off
up there for the last ten thousand years
and this led researchers to conclude
that climate changes have been small and
uninteresting during this period of
human civilizations other archives tell
a different story
they illustrate the fact that
temperatures warming or cooling are not
necessarily the most important things
going on in climate more critical to the
fate of human societies is changes in
patterns of precipitation the
availability of water look at this
profile of client of climate from the
sediments of Moon Lake North Dakota this
is a pattern of climate is this ekaterna
climate stability it looks to me more
like abrupt change notice the relative
magnitude in the duration of the
terrible infamous Dust Bowl pattern that
was such an iconic the catastrophe for
this country that's the Dust Bowl just
that little squiggle right there
notice they noticed a long book notice a
long periods of drought how does these
areas just vast stretches of a long
drought 50 60 you know 100 years at a
time you know that's that's to me that
is the most fearful look you know Indian
in the sense likely abrupt climate
change to worry about him you know big
drought could come along and just you
know knock knock this country on its ear
it could last 50 years I mean you can
see the climate system
this is the boring Holocene you know
this is just the last two thousand years
the climate system is capable of doing
some real real nasty nasty changes by
beginning the talk of the implications
of climate change with global warming I
saw the throat blown my punch line in
the sense but let me close with an
observation about the political context
of questions before us this whole
subject does not really lend itself to
blind partisanship you know I think we
should resist the temptation to demonize
people who disagree with with us about
it
earth scientists are in the business of
figuring out how the world works you
know it's a continuing process conjuring
up really strongly held views about how
climate behaves makes no more sense than
passionate disputations about the causes
of earthquakes there if if an abrupt
change were to you know surprise us as
inevitably it would surprise us if it
were to happen you know there's a lot of
mysteries out there about the climate
the future is uncertain there are going
to be surprises and we're if we're going
to have to adapt successful each other
we're going to have to be open-minded
and flexible and I think you know that
it's just it's just an ongoing learning
process about the climate and what we're
doing you know what what it's going to
do to us and I think we should just keep
relatively open
and you know and be nicer to each other
about it because it's going to require
you know some changes in institutional
thinking and other than other other
changes if something like one of these
droughts or something came along in the
you know and whacked us anyway there's
there's abrupt climate change play
anybody have any question to be happy to
tackle them
kind of each other
place in the middle you can talk about
one end is
scary the other bid
well I think there are things we could
do right now I I don't you know I don't
mean to imply that you know that we
ought to just give it up there's I mean
there's all kinds of really good reasons
to lower industrial pollution levels
including you know you know having some
effect on a continuing warming of the
atmosphere I'm just saying that there's
you know there's other there's other
things out there that we have to I think
we are betting that it's going to go
easy on us you know and that we have
control over it and I think we are being
optimistic if not naive you know in
terms of the potential for change you
know I think you know and you know
people who make up their mind really
strongly about do these things this
business stuff that came out of the you
know the Greenland ice cores in 1995 you
know a lot of people have already made
up their mind about this before you know
before the natural patterns of the
climate variability we're even even
known you know - any any serious extent
so I think it's just you know I think we
have a there the stakes are higher and
we have to be more careful than we than
we think we do about it in bed then
there's high probability that there are
going to be surprises ahead what what
kind of policy implications would that
give us what what would we do if we were
if people who believed that what you're
saying was probably true what would what
would we do in that circumstance well I
think we have to I think they're all
kinds of institutional constraints
against adaptation you know modern
societies have property right issues and
all kinds of ownership issues and and
real estate issues and other regulatory
issues that if you
in infrastructures that depend on storm
tracks arriving at a certain place and
you know so the water supply is a stable
there's all kinds of things that that
invest us in stability so I think if
there's going to be instability if
there's going to be so kind of you know
rapid change almost to the point of a
public emergency situation you know
we're growing areas or you know
agricultural areas are no longer going
to get sufficient water etc you have to
be able to sort of think outside the box
and you know and do things
be prepared to do things on you know on
a different level than you might
otherwise do not answering your question
specifically but I think I think we
should do everything we can to avoid
such a thing happening and if it still
happens you know we're going to have to
be prepared to do you know do things
that sort of unthinkable things about
changing certain habits you know that
there's a an interesting corollary to
some of this in a way and that is in the
10th century the first European
settlement in the West was was created
by the Norse in Greenland you know and
it was a entirely successful colony for
the better part of 400 years and then it
died out you know and there's a you know
the interesting story about how climate
changed up there abruptly and and
suddenly just you know it gets the old
you know the anonymous author said you
know it got cold and they died well you
know they've looked into that with the
ice core work and the isotope work that
they've been able to do with some really
detailed now and they've also you know
this interdisciplinary approaches have
looked at this question you know more
thoroughly you know the the Greenland
North Greenland colony this European
colony failed at the very time that the
native into it was was thriving in that
condition you know why did the Norse
fail and the inoue thrive it's because
they didn't adapt you know they were
unable to change their culture to adopt
you know you know successful
technologies the the Inuit employed
first you know for a hunting seal you
know they had these skin boats that were
able to just pick up over the ice and
you know and and slide along and put
them back down in in the water you know
the it was just this this sense of this
culture identity that you know that
permitted that allowed the Norse to
choose extinction in a sense over you
know over the adoption of the culture of
the new pagan you know wit that they
despised so you know there is a case of
adaptation failure you know we look at
it now say well those fools
you know it was right there all they had
to do is was you know adopt the you know
the hinged harpoon and that kind of
thing like the intimate had all they had
to do is change their boats that kind of
thing well you know we'll see I mean
some of the some of the resistance that
we see in the political level this is
kind of the song that we're singing to
ourselves about whether we're adapting
or not you know I mean we can all decide
how successfully that's completely but
in a way it's you know it's like it's
like the Old Norse you know they decided
that they weren't going to change by God
they were going to keep their ties to
the church and they were going to you
know continue the everything Europeana
they could think of and you know they
are you have a lot of data
and that shows that clock there's been a
lot of climate change in the past but
what we know about the mechanisms and
privilege for this change well I
mentioned the prevailing or I guess the
favorite story is the idea that the
thermohaline circulation in the North
Atlantic this overturning of you know of
warm you know the Gulf Stream is part of
it you know it goes down and then it
gets cold and and grows in density and
drops to the abyss and then it comes
back as as cold and you know this
overturning this conveyor quality
Brokers so great conveyor well there was
a there was a freshwater flood during
the melting of the Laurentide Ice Sheet
this enormous Lake was held back by the
by the ice sheet well suddenly a you
know a nice dam broke and it's this
whole Lake drained into the North
Atlantic within you know a very short
period of time and so freshened the the
surface water that it changed the
density and and prevented the
overturning in the North Atlantic so
they so the warmth didn't go up that far
I mean there was you know at one time
they were thinking that it stopped the
conveyor altogether and so the transport
of these of this tropical warmth no
longer went into the North Atlantic it
iced over and there you had you know the
Younger Dryas for example there you had
other other cold
events in this in this jagged in this
Jack jagged profile well you know that's
a good story it made you know it may be
true for several of them but it's kind
of a doubt and a lot of researchers mind
that that really accounts for all of the
abrupt changes that you see you know a
lot of people suggest the tropics have
to be involved I mean you have all of
this energy in the tropics and all this
very small amount of energy in the in
the North Atlantic and likelihood is
that this you know this this boiler room
of the climate behavior that is going on
in the tropics has something to do with
these changes that we see that are so
that is so widespread and abrupt also -
I think you know the first people who
sort of looked into this problem were
you know from the North Atlantic so we
you know we we got our story down first
but I'm sure there's other other
mechanisms that are that are at work I
don't think it sort of matters in sense
you know for for our non-scientists
purposes I think it just you know the
nature of the beast is now known would
you project that there's probably a
better chance at least of the abrupt
change happening on a regional scale at
least in the near term where one
continent might be specially affected
without necessarily having been
triggered something that something over
there could be quite drastic for in
evaporation would be or what does the
Paleo worked in to suggest I'm not sure
I can answer that question there's
there's a lot of there's a lot of this
kind of pattern in Africa for example
there's a lot of places in the world
where drought you know has been a very
serious you know problem I mean you know
I have a whole chapter devoted to you
know the question of climates effect on
the collapse of civilizations and you
know this pattern shows up in a lot of
places around the world you know whether
or not it could you know as part of
abrupt change in a sense doesn't matter
abrupt change you know it's where you
find it is where you live it and so I
don't I think we know we know that that
droughts in particular have affected
every major civilization you know and
the Mayas and the Egyptians and all
kinds of civilizations have have been
affected you know some to the
catastrophic degree in others others
less so than then we realized before the
you know before the climate systems on
rhiness was was
was known to us in a sense I think it's
sort of the the Paleo work sort of woke
people up to the idea that well you know
climate has clearly been you know a
factor in a lot more of the Holocene
record than then we would have supposed
and I don't know that I've answered your
question specifically about regional
events but that they're you know the
history of civilizations is probably for
to look for a lot of regional climate
change
I was wondering how would you respond to
the argument that for example with
respect to the climate record you're
talking about for the past 100,000 years
you know it shows abrupt climate change
well that's over you know that's in
geological time you know I mean I'm not
exactly sure how often that abrupt
climate changes occurred those sort of
snapped occurred in the past hundred
thousand years but if they've occurred
let's say every two thousand three
thousand years there's really no way to
know exactly when it's going to happen
you know so why why even bother I mean
and the other thing is that of course
you mean you say that you know the past
10,000 years or at least since then at
the end or dry it's been abnormally
having a homogeneous and warm but well
since you know geologists say we're in a
new era the Holocene era you know those
tend to last a very long time so who you
know who's to say that it is sort of
normally warm homogeneous climate is not
going to continue for a very long time
yeah well I think your your your
assumption about it and our general
assumption about the old Essene being
you know relatively stable is has just
been you know it's just just plain wrong
you know if you look only at the
temperature record you'll you'll you'll
make that conclusion but if you look at
this record you know this is not
stability you know this is not been
benign climate you know this disc and
this is scary
you know I mean there's there's major
episodes of drought that lasted for 50
100 years so I you know and this is
North America I think the idea that it
can happen it you know as you say it is
unpredictable
you know that that's the message
it is unpredictable I mean I think what
I'm trying to convey with this book is
that we are generally assuming for the
best that it is relatively predictable
relatively controllable and relatively
slow and all of those I think are
serious in serious doubt when you look
at the record of natural climate change
bring up such an issue I'm a little
embarrassed to bring this up I'm not a
scientist so maybe I can get away with
it as you spoke I'm thinking about the
hurricane class with earlier this week
and I'm thinking about the quantity of
moisture water but ever fell on Alabama
Florida so I'm wondering if there's some
way this has nothing to climate change
but I'm trying to think of some way we
can take advantage of that residue of
that storm
somehow channel the water make canals
this will take it to Arizona or the
driver Tennessee why I'm embarrassed
gie yeah I don't know that'd be great
I think there's I think there's I mean
incredibly expensive but you know I
think there's a lot of room for
rethinking some of our some of our ways
of storing and transporting water I mean
I live out in California you know the
whole western United States is is built
on this idea that the storms are going
to come at a certain angle and that
they're going to arrive with the
temperature so that most of them come as
snow snow storms on the mountains you
change you know you change atmospheric
temperatures by a couple degrees and
those storms come as rain and if they
come as rain instead of snow you know
sounds like a minor thing they come as
rain instead of snow we don't have that
snowpack up there to live on it's going
to change our ability to support a
certain you know population a certain
level of life I mean that kind of thing
I mean I'm talking about an enormous
of this country there is so you know so
dependent on the phase of water you know
that that we you know not only not only
would we not have the storage capacity
for the fresh water that we need for
during the rest of you know for a big
part of the year but if it all arrives
as water we've got floods on our hands
like crazy because our dams aren't big
enough to hold all the water they you
know they they're assuming that it's
going to come as snow - anyway I like to
think our speaker right watch thank you
and just to let all of you know john cox
will be signing copies of his book and
the lobby after the event so you're
welcome to buy a copy if you don't
already have one to go through and also
the museum is open so you're welcome to
go back and we actually have an exhibit
on the Younger Dryas if you'd like to
take a look John Cox is author of storm
watchers and weather for dummies his
latest climate crash is published by
joseph henry press visit JH press comm
for more information